in Finsbury Park London a 48 year old
whites presumably non-muslim man killed
one person and injured what appear to be
ten people near a mosque the driver
plowed into a crowd of Moscow errs
members of the public restrained the
driver of the van until police arrived
this was just after midnight as evening
Ramadan prayers were finishing British
Prime Minister Theresa May said that the
attack was directed at Muslims and
condemned it as quote every bit as
sickening as deadly Islamist attacks
that hit the country in the recent
months that we've been covering pretty
extensively police believe that the
attacker was acting alone
there were some initial reports from
witnesses who said that they saw two
other people fleeing the scene not
necessarily fleeing the vehicle that was
used and of course when something like
this happens people flee not because
they are afraid not necessarily because
they are involved in the event and that
is exactly what it appears to have been
a Muslim welfare house CEO tewfiq Kazemi
said that the attacker shouted quote I
did my bit you deserve it an imam
prevented people from taking revenge on
the man he said this is of course being
considered a terrorist incident as it
should be an attack on Muslims
specifically because they are Muslims so
there are a few angles here one is that
this idea of Muslims as perpetrators of
terror as well as being victims of
terror and this is something that also
happens when we talk about the Islamic
state pad there's often the false notion
that it's Muslims as perpetrators of
terror only against non-muslims and
Muslims as victims of terror only at the
hands of non-muslims but Isis does not
like Muslims who do not believe their
worldview Isis does not like Muslims who
no longer are practicing Muslims we've
talked about sectarian intra muscle and
violence for a very very long time so
that's one angle here and some people
will see it just a that way and I think
there's a lot more to discuss there yeah
I mean we don't know
too much about this man or his motives
yet but you have to imagine that he's
trying to find some sort of vengeance
for the Islamist acts of terror that
happened from time to time seeming but
does he realize that he's becoming a
terrorist himself that's the next thing
I want to talk about which is you might
see this and say okay there was the
Ariana Grande attack or the other
incident on the bridge with someone
whatever incident you want to talk about
where it was Muslim perpetrators of
terror and then you might see this
incident you would say oh this is the
opposite of the recent attacks because
it is a non Muslim attacking Muslims
that's one angle but as pat is pointing
out there's another way that you can
give you this up which is that this
attack where it was a non-muslim
attacking Muslims is the same as attacks
in which Muslims attack non-muslims in
that these are all attacks where people
are saying hey you know what I think I'm
justified in killing innocent people and
it doesn't matter what the religions are
that is a small portion of the people on
this planet thankfully which is that
these are all individuals that think oh
I have some gripe or whatever I am going
to go out and kill innocent victims and
that's an acceptable way of exploring my
grievances and that obviously is
something we disagree with but that's
something that ties these attacks
together as you're pointing out it's
like Timothy McVeigh killing 168 people
in Oklahoma City to avenge for the
deaths at Waco yeah is it really worth
it though trying to get inside the heads
of these perpetrators because it's
really hard to appeal to logic and
reason with them it is but it's worth it
in that we know that you can't bomb your
way to peace right that we're talking
about ideology as as what is causing
this so I think that although it's
difficult to get as in the head as
you're suggesting Pat we need to be
thinking about how one gets to this type
of radicalization and what this forty
eight year old white dude doesn't
realize is that he's doing what Isis
would do anyway right Isis doesn't
discriminate between killing Muslims and
non-muslims if you're a Muslim trying to
integrate into Western society you're an
enemy of Isis as well if you're the
wrong type of Muslim you're worthy of
death as well according to the radicals
that are in Isis Oh
is the sick reality is that if you talk
to these individuals they would say no
we're only attacking people who deserve
it we're not attacking so-called
innocence
we're attacking people who are part of
the problem and they are not actually
innocent and at a sort of 30,000 foot
level the idea of using terror attacks
to respond to other terror attacks is
pretty disturbing in terms of possible
escalation inter-religious strife and
warfare are exactly what groups like the
Islamic state are hoping to incite and
as we've talked about it was either last
week or the week before Theresa May in
response to what's going on wants to
regulate the internet because of all the
people driving vehicles into innocent
people and we've talked about how that
makes absolutely no sense either